50 protesters were killed on sunday the
worst day of violence
in a month and a half long crackdown on
the anti-coup movement
demonstrators defied martial law on
monday where they were again
met with live ammunition killing six
more protesters scott hydler
reports
the deadliest area on the most violent
day of the anti-coup protests on sunday
was in leitaya
an industrial suburb of yangon
more than 30 unarmed protesters were
killed with live ammunition
some of the protesters there targeted
factories financed by china
many protesters say the country is
supporting the coup
global times a chinese state-run
newspaper said factories were attacked
and set on fire by so-called instigators
and causing 37 million dollars in damage
it prompted the strongest statement yet
from china calling the situation very
severe and urging myanmar's generals to
stop all acts of violence
punish the perpetrators and protect
chinese people and companies
its large influential neighbor to the
north china is by far
the largest trading partner with myanmar
and is the biggest supply of arms and
military equipment to the tap
myanmar's army after sunday's violent
crackdown in vandalism the junta
announced that at least six areas in
yangon are now
under martial law
in smaller groups than on sunday
protesters came out again on the streets
of mandalay on monday
marching against the junta and
supporting their democratically elected
leaders
ousted civilian leader aung sang-soo-chi
was to have another court hearing on the
charges against her including one added
last week
accusing her of accepting illegal
payments but the hearing was pushed back
today though aung san tsuji's case was
adjourned to
24th of this month
the case it cannot be just could not be
conducted this day today
because we have got no internet
in the country for the whole country
like this six weeks on the protesters
resolve has remained
constant but according to some they've
had to
increase their willingness to sacrifice
freedom from the meaning of the tattoo
is freedom from fear they threatened us
with weapons
but our revolution won't win if we have
fear so we must get rid of this kind of
fear to prevail in our revolution
the term revolution now increasingly
being used by those out on the streets
protesting
but it's now also being used by a
civilian parallel government
saying revolution is needed to overturn
the coup
scott heidler al jazeera